tu sais ce que c'est que de vivre avec
un ado attardé pendant dix ans un jour
peut-être chez pas que j'aurais envie de
fonder une famille et on fait pas un
enfant avec un enfant
un vrai mec c'est un mec est un boulot
un minimum d'ambition du coup on fait
pas l'amour
bon j'ai décidé de monter une crèche à
domicile c'est sympa et économique du
boulot me manquait pour pas laisser
votre enfant ici ce décret chiffon 8h21
ans raconte pas les rues vous avez une
heure france vraiment très bien fait
d'arrêter certains petits grandissent et
c'est mon frère mais y connais rien en
éducation var été arrêté à et démerdez
vous j'espère que vous aimez ça le mcdo
parce que vous allez en manger tous les
jours
au port
termine ce soir là mais pourquoi parce
que sinon je balance la vidéo du bdk
failli tomber à tous tes clients au
hasard si tu fais ça moi je balance sur
internet le film qu'on a fait des thés
dernier en espagne reilly le rafting
dans le fucking paquin et des techniques
pour endormir les deux suisses rsa ça me
fait pas du tout pour les sortir faut
qu'ils se dépensent emmène les au parc
voulait toujours pas de faire la sieste
continuer à courir 5
qu'est ce qu'un type comme toi peut
apprendre à des mioches
pas si mature que ça tombe à 15
[Musique]
effectuez brailler et le petit là bas
c'est quand justin bieber ah oui pour la
mèche
[Musique]